what's going on people i'm dave rubin
this is the reuben report direct message
for today wednesday june
9th 2021 do me a favor would you do me a
favor right now would you stop
everything you're doing put down the hot
dog
push aside all your papers and other
things that you've got in front of your
computer
take the mouse do you have a mouse over
there on your computer or your little
touch thingy
and tap that subscription button on the
youtube page
tap the notification bell share our
videos blah blah
blah blah blah blah do all that stuff
for me would you do that and then maybe
you'll
see our videos we got a big show for you
today uh i should warn you guys
i've got a bit of a toothache and i was
already at the dentist this morning i
think i'm going to be able to make it
through the show
but if there's any sort of medical
emergency michael you're going to you're
gonna step in for me
michael will step in if i pass out uh
due to the pain i think i'm gonna be
okay i have a follow-up appointment in a
couple weeks a little
little little ache sensitive to cold
we're gonna figure it out it's gonna be
all right people
all right we got three stories for you
today uh the first one
i think is probably the most interesting
because it's a jump off of yesterday's
story
about this new york times reporter mara
gay who was triggered when she saw
american flags uh in long island
on trucks and obviously the american
flag is a synonym for
white supremacist racist stuff and then
the reason that i'm doing the follow-up
story is because the new york times
tweeted out a defense of her that people
the sort of implication is people like
me are are misconstruing her words well
we're going to show you the video and
read
the actual tweet that they sent and show
you some other things that she's done
in her day the second story you're
definitely not going to see this on cnn
washington post new york times msnbc
or any of corporate media i checked this
morning it's not anywhere
is that some hunter biden text messages
have leaked now
just for the record i'm not a fan of
reading leaked emails i'm not a fan of
reading
leaked texts or secret recordings of
people or any of those
things i don't even actually care about
the content
of his personal text messages however
the issue with this is that he said the
n-word repeatedly
in these texts that have been leaked
these were to his lawyer who is white he
repeatedly
referred to him as the n word i'll read
you the text
and we'll discuss the sort of linguistic
trickery
uh around using certain words and
knowing that i have to say a word
the n word obviously i can't say the
word then i'll be
canceled or my youtube channel will be
taken out but that's really not even
what this is about it's mostly about the
fact
that i'm fairly certain and i think
you'll just go along with me on this
adventure
i'm fairly certain that if one of donald
trump's children
had been caught saying the n-word that
it might have been covered on cnn or
msnbc or the new york times
or washington post and yesterday i
talked about uh how the mainstream media
basically
launders lies and one of the ways they
do this is not just by making up stories
that go through the system so you know
it's a washington post op-ed
that we talk about on msnbc and we bring
a new york times
journalist journalist to cover sort of
like the mara gay thing that we talked
about yesterday
but it's also the stories that they
won't cover that's one way you launder
lies
because if you just won't cover
something because it doesn't fit the
narrative
well you've laundered the lie and that's
exactly what they're doing so again i
don't really care about the specifics
about hunter biden and smoke and crack
out of the carpet and whatever the other
nonsense he's doing
this is more about the irresponsibility
of the mainstream media
and then the third story is that
hydrochloroquine which for about a year
or so people have been saying including
many medical doctors
have been saying is one of the things
that you can take
to avoid kovid and that it can really
help and that we don't need lockdowns
and masks aren't effective and all sorts
of stuff
well now there's some studies that
actually prove that that's
the case uh i suppose even me saying
that right there could get me in trouble
with the youtube god so it's a it's
probable
and we're gonna show you some evidence
uh and some studies and things of that
nature but first let's talk
about this uh it's new york times
journalist marigay and again i i said
this yesterday i really do mean i don't
mean to make this about her but this is
this is just sort of the endless
ridiculousness
that mainstream media does so what they
did yesterday on msnbc was they took an
op-ed piece about scary trump supporters
you know implying that they're all white
supremacists written by this guy max
boot
who's just one of these pet republicans
who's never defended any sort of
conservative value everybody so he's
loved by msnbc right
so he writes an op-ed in the washington
post they then discuss
that on chuck scarborough not chuck
scarborough that guy was on msnbc joe
scarborough
chuck scarborough that is a great
reference for those of you from new york
in the 80s and 90s if you got that
reference
high five to you he went uh this is joe
scarborough's show
on msnbc they start analyzing
this piece in the washington post and
they bring on
marigay who's a new york times
journalist
to talk about it and this is the launder
of lies where they just all link
together
and then they just promote a narrative
that they want to get out there
well let's just throw you the video from
yesterday that caught fire let's do that
first i was on long island this weekend
uh visiting a really
dear friend and i was really disturbed i
saw you know
dozens and dozens of pickup trucks with
uh
you know explicatives against joe biden
on the back of them trump flags
and some cases just dozens of american
flags
which you know uh is also just
disturbing because essentially the
message was clear it was
this is my country this is not your
country
i own this and so until we're ready
to have that conversation this is going
to continue
okay so she's saying she saw dozens of
trucks with
explicatives i think she means
expletives about
joe biden now i just first off i just
don't believe that like where are the
pictures like what are you saying it was
f joe biden and
screw joe biden and blah blah blah like
i just don't believe it like
why haven't i seen any pictures by the
way when trump was president we saw that
stuff
everywhere i live in los angeles
everywhere you went there were all sorts
of things
calling him hitler and a nazi and all
sorts of evil stuff so
hey i don't believe that but i'll grant
her that okay that's fine then she said
she saw trump flags
okay well if you can have any sort of
political flag you know pro-biden
flag you can have a trump flag that that
doesn't mean you're a white supremacist
i know in your mind it does
but then the final thing and the thing
that sort of caught
the eye of the internet was that she saw
these dozens of american flags and that
to her
was this implication that these people
they want their country back
basically and of course they're they
these people see everything through the
lens
of imaginary white supremacy and all of
this stuff
uh anyway that clip went viral because
it's a ridiculous
thing to say the american flag has
nothing to do
with racism we have fought racism we
fought a civil war
to end slavery we had a black president
most european countries that have
existed for hundreds if not thousands of
years longer than us have not had
uh black presidents or prime ministers
doesn't mean everything's perfect but
things are pretty freaking good here but
this just goes to show
once you've accepted the woke ideology
once you've accepted critical race
all of these people they live in an
imaginary world where she's literally
seeing people with the american flag
driving down the long island expressway
and thinking that they're white
supremacists
it's absolutely crazy absolutely crazy i
have american flags i'm not a white
supremacist okay it's just
it's just completely ridiculous so
anyway this clip went around
uh twitter started going viral so then
she marget tweeted
this let's get that tweet up there she
said
uh i see i'm being trolled with the
american flag this morning
trolling a black journalist with the
american flag is not
the own some people think it is now i
don't know how you can be trolled
by the american flag i just i don't even
know what that means and your color of
your skin is completely irrelevant
if a white person had said the exact
same thing i would be covering the story
and i think
it would have gone just as viral but i
get it
once you have chosen the woke ideology
you have to use your skin color and
whatever your perceived impressions are
as sort of the most important thing
about you so you think you somehow get
some sort of pass
or something because of your stupid
comment because you're black but that's
just not how reality works and i refuse
to play
these nonsensical games well then this
is why i wanted to cover the story today
it wasn't just to repeat yesterday's
thing and show you her tweet
it was because the new york times public
relations account
on twitter actually defended her they
tweeted out this
new york times editorial board member
mara gaye's comments on msnbc have been
irresponsibly
taken out of context her argument was
that trump and many of his supporters
have politicized the american flag
the attacks on her today are
ill-informed and grounded in bad faith
now first off
it's an odd thing for them to do because
they're commenting on
other people's opinions about her
opinion right so what does that have to
do with
pr for the new york times like the new
york times pr
account should be defending their
articles or
the the way that their articles are
viewed that sort of thing but now
they're
sort of they're acting as basically like
the
bodyguard for one of their reporters who
made a comment now
nobody said anything about her
and the american flag she's the one that
did it right like she's the one
that actually implied that the american
flag has something to do
with white supremacy like so it's just a
lie and then they got ratioed
to high hell and the reason i mention
all of this
is because the implication that the new
york times and that she's putting out is
that these are bad
faith actors that's what the words that
the new york times pr
account use these are uh ill-informed
and grounded in bad faith these people
that are talking about her
um well if that's the case uh i've got a
quote
from mara gay uh just from about two
weeks ago
in the new york times she was
interviewing andrew yang and let's let's
listen to some bad faith stuff if they
think that's bad fee
this is marigay to andreang you've built
your brand by
frequently doing radio and other
appearances with right wing media
personalities
at times you said that the democratic
party should gravitate away from
identity politics
you've supported automating fast food
workers at times
why appear on shows like the dave rubin
show
who regularly hosts white supremacists
huh well i'm dave rubin now i host a
show called the reuben report
i don't know what the dave rubin show is
i asked mara gay
to retract and correct that simply
because you got the name of the show
wrong but of course they didn't do that
i don't regularly host white
supremacists either
so would you say that is bad faith
margay why did the new york times
not offer me a defense there but this is
consistently what these people do and by
the way the new york times this is the
same paper that as you guys know once
did a sunday cover story about how me
and jordan peterson
and ben shapiro and nobel prize winning
economist milton friedman lead people
to the alt-right huge picture of my face
about the the
way youtube is leading people to the
alt-right uh the new york times also ran
when when jordan and i jordan peterson
and i when we left patreon
we actually left patreon because
somebody on patreon got booted with no
recourse
and we decided to leave patreon new york
times covered it had four factual errors
in there in their story which i
contacted the reporter
and she refused to correct any of the
things so the new york times is not a
newspaper
i think what you're seeing here and the
reason i wanted to do the story again is
not to make it about her
but it's to make it about how the the
media just makes
up nonsense they launder lies through
op-eds that make it onto cable news
channels that then get
their own writers at places like the new
york times to comment on it
and then when people push back against
their lies the implication that the
united states and the american flag are
racist and white supremacists and all
that stuff
when people push back on it then they
basically call all of
us liars so that is the way the game is
played and we have to call it out for
what it is for as long as these people
have any sort of cultural power and by
the way their cultural power is waning
that that's the beautiful thing
less and less people are paying
attention well nobody watches msnbc
really
less and less serious people are paying
attention to the new york times
the washington post is trash like
everyone is sort of getting it but as
long as they have any cultural power
within the institutions that are sort of
above all of us unfortunately
we've got to push back on it so i hope
that that gave you a little
insight into how how evil spreads right
like
like it's it's genuinely evil i don't
like using terms
like good and evil in these things but
but if you lie
if you lie and then you push that lie
through the system with other liars we
gotta push back we gotta push back it's
as simple as that
uh before i get to the other two stories
i want to talk to you guys about
uh some email services let's get to it
you know free email services like gmail
and yahoo aren't really free you pay
with your privacy
and since those companies have access to
everything that you send and receive big
tech can sell your data to the highest
bidder
from business plans to medical records
companies can sell your personal data
to target you with intrusive ads and
open you up to identity theft and
phishing attacks
that's why start mail wants to secure
your email and make you feel
safe again start mail keeps your email
private period
every email is encrypted even the if the
recipient doesn't use the encryption
which means big tech can't read scan
analyze or sell your personal
information
ever start mail also prevents government
agencies from spying on you like in
dragnet operations
with start mail deleted means deleted
when you delete an email it's gone
forever and start mail uses their own
servers not amazon's
which means they can't be put out of
business like parlor start mail is also
backed by the most stringent privacy
laws in the world you get unlimited
anonymous aliases this feature protects
your main email address
from spam and phishing attacks so when
you're giving your email to a company
but want to protect your identity start
mail can generate a shareable alias
email
so people can't sell your info and they
can be deleted
any time here at the reuben report we've
been looking forward
to finding alternatives to google so
we're excited by what start mail has to
offer
i don't trust big tech and neither
should you start securing your email
privacy with start mail
sign up today and you'll get fifty
percent off your first year go to start
mail.com
reuben that's start mail with the t
s-t-a-r-t
mail.com ruben for 50 off your first
year start mail.com
reuben and now back to me quickly before
i get to this next story that you're not
going to see
on corporate media unfortunately i just
want to say one last thing on the
previous story because i
repeatedly said that i don't want to
make it about this girl and i don't want
to make it about this girl even though
she has
libeled me in the new york times i am
not trying to direct
anger towards her i'm trying to show you
a broader uh
picture of what's going on here and i
just want to be very clear about that
because i get that the internet brings
the worst out in everybody
twitter brings the worst down everybody
um and it's like when you see these lies
do you do you either do you push back
and do you call it out or do you just
sit there and drown slowly
should we all just be the frog in the
slowly boiling pot i just refuse to be
that frog anymore and we have to push
back and occasionally
you gotta you gotta make it about some
of the people that are laundering those
lies okay
speaking of laundering lies one way that
you can launder lies is if you don't
talk about stories that you would
otherwise
talk about if they fit your political
narrative
and uh hunter biden you may remember
this guy he is the crack smoking son
of the president of the united states
remember he was at one point looking
through carpet
to snort anything he claims that he
might have snorted some parmesan cheese
thinking it was
thinking it was crack well you may
remember that his
laptop was found by the new york post
before the election
we were not allowed to tweet about that
because uh
well we don't really know why but they
basically were censoring the new york
post
before the election then it came out
after the election once
biden won and then they got what they
wanted in essence they got joe biden
president then we could talk about it
again
then hunter biden went on that he got
new teeth and he went on this
tour went on jimmy kimmel talk about
what a great guy he is all of that stuff
well now it's come out that some text
messages of his
have leaked and he repeatedly uses the
n-word i am not here to police people's
language okay i just want to be clear
about that like you could say whatever
the hell you want
and your private life and you can be a
racist and a prick and an
entitled [ __ ] and all of those things
the reason i am covering the story is
sort of why i covered the first story
which is
i'm pretty sure if trump jr had said the
n-word this would be
everywhere in main street this would be
literally leading everything right now
and it's being completely ignored brian
stelter of reliable
sources not covering it jake tapper of
whatever the jake tapper show is
not covering it somehow he didn't make
it into the situation room with wolf
or whatever acosta does or lemons showed
somehow these people
they all miss this story very bizarre i
know it's weird but here we've got
some info from the new york post first
son hunter biden repeatedly called his
white attorney the n-word in a pair of
bizarre
and occasionally lewd conversations in
late 2018 and early 2019
according to newly unearthed messages
okay so we're going to put these
messages up here now remember
i don't want to say the word this has
nothing to do with the word
the fact that even if i if i i mean this
is the iron wait come back to me for a
second
this is the irony of of this situation
right now so i'm going to read you these
things and i'm going to say the n word
i'm not going to say the word itself
okay
but if i was to just repeat what hunter
biden
says in these text messages i'm fairly
certain my youtube channel
could be deleted yet the mainstream
media won't even cover
that he did this in the first place that
is why this is a story not the specifics
of what's in here but now let's throw to
the
to the text messages he's in blue and
it's his lawyer in
white and and for the record uh his
lawyer is white
as well there is zero coverage or pickup
of the story zip
they spent a [ __ ] ton of resources on it
too for a year
wow thank you michael cohen then he gave
the you know the finger there
oh and you too how much money do i owe
you because n word
you better not be charging me hennessy
rates
that made me snarfs made that phrase up
by the way i should have
i should have nad your lineage had i
guess he means
clever son of a gun it's wasted on you
apparently you do that's what i'm saying
then there's some image there
why are you so tan ah we'll just get to
the next one anyway he says it again
at the bottom of the next one you can
say true dat n word okay
i wanna the other part that i wanted to
talk about related to this
is that we are living in a time of mass
cancellations we're living in a time
where
people they go back they find something
you said 10 years ago doesn't matter if
you were 15 when they said it
they cancel aunt jemima okay they cancel
uncle ben
we got rid of the lando lakes ladies
we're cancelling things left and right
we are told that racism
and the and just is the driving force in
everything in the world right now
and that destroying racism and being an
anti-racist
is the most important thing well if
saying that word is bad which is what
we've been told well then why is nobody
going after him where where is black
lives matter now going after him where
is anyone in mainstream media going
after him where are the
the brave progressive warriors for truth
going after him
none of them are and that's how you know
the whole thing is a grift
and a shell game and nonsense and they
would use
this to destroy anyone else that was a
conservative or on the right or anything
else and i want to mention
uh if you think i'm making this stuff
this stuff up
my friend kyle kashuv who used to work
for us here at the reuben report who was
one of the survivors
of the parkland shooting i hope you've
seen my episode with kyle and i and i
certainly hope you know kyle because
he's
he's an extraordinary young man who's
going to do great things in this world
uh well kyle what graduated first in his
class
okay and if you remember after the
parkland shooting most of the kids
became
anti-gun activists kyle was basically
the one kid who became a pro-second
amendment
activist uh he was treated horribly by
the media while the rest of them
were treated like heroes we we know all
that kind of stuff
well it kyle then because he was number
one at harvard got into uh sorry
number one in high school uh graduating
class got into harvard university
and then because some students didn't
like him anymore because of his activism
on the second amendment to defend the
second amendment
they leaked some google documents that
kyle was in when he was in like ninth
and tenth grade
when he said some bad words including
the n-word he did they were killed they
were joking around and kids do stuff and
everyone
everyone has said every bad word myself
included okay
nobody's innocent here these
self-righteous pricks well you know what
harvard then kicked him out they
rescinded his offer
so they got rid of the kid who stood up
against the mob by defending the second
amendment who graduated number one his
class
and then they let in david hogg by the
way who didn't have the
the grades to get in there but he was a
you know a progressive hero
uh and he's and he's pretty stupid quite
frankly
um and anyway i mentioned this because
let me just get this straight if this is
how the public game
is played that we destroy a kid who can
graduate number one in his class and
make it to harvard he can no longer go
to harvard but the president's son when
he does these things
on top of the fact that the president's
on who was getting what like 50 grand
a month from barisma to be an energy
consultant who had absolutely no
background and obviously used all of his
dad's
leverage and and power to get that gig
and a whole bunch of really i mean
there's the video of biden literally
saying that they were going to fire
the prosecutor in ukraine like there
it's it's such deep corruption
um also you know i mentioned this i
vaguely mentioned this in the first
story but
uh sargon of akkad who was a big
youtuber for many years he was one of
the sort of first
sort of disaffected liberal types he was
banned
from patreon uh because he said
the n-word not to be racist he said the
n-word
because he was mocking people that used
the n-word and patreon
blew up his account completely
demolished his business
that actually this is what i was
referencing that actually was when i
just started
decided to create locals because i
realized i shouldn't be on patreon
anymore
because these these uh rules that these
tech companies set up are completely
arbitrary
so kyle sargon the litany of people who
have been destroyed in their personal
lives
for far less than the deep corruption
and
drug use and everything else that that
hunter biden has done and i don't even
care about any of that stuff i don't
care what language he uses i don't care
what drugs he does
i care about the disconnect in the media
and the way
that we're all being manipulated it's
like we're playing a game
with rules that are set for some people
and rules that are set for other people
and we all keep playing
and we got to figure out a way how to
play this game a little bit better i
suspect that the only way we're going to
do it
is by building new things that's why i
started locals and if
and if i dared to say the very word
that hunter biden said in these texts my
i would be kicked off youtube right now
but thankfully because of
reubenreport.locals.com
i would not be gone forever because you
got to build stuff instead of just
playing along with these people
and speaking of their endless nonsense
there's been a real through line to the
show today you know sometimes this
we could bounce around with stories but
there's been a real through line no more
bs
i've just about had it with your endless
bs uh well you may
remember that early on starting really i
would say in last spring but then it got
really hot
in the summer there were a bunch of
doctors and a bunch of people online who
were talking about hydrochloroquine
and hydrochloroquine is a medicine that
many doctors were saying
at least could help prevent covid plenty
of people were booted from twitter from
this
videos were taken down on youtube
channels were deleted
doctors had their reputations destroyed
mobs going after their their jobs and
families and all of those things
well now there is a new study that says
that hydrochloroquine
is probably quite effective in dealing
with covalent let's throw to fox news
and now over a year later we have that
data that dr stephen smith promised in a
new study
smith and three other medical experts
prove what he and his this show have
been telling you for more than a year
that hydroxychloroquine can save lives
smith's landmark study followed 255
covid patients who required intubation
during the first two months of the
pandemic
and it found that increased doses of
co-administered hydroxychloroquine and
azithromycin
were associated with a greater than 100
percent
increase in survival
that's a study using science
saying some stuff now i'm not telling
you it's 100
true but the point is that many doctors
and reputable people and a small amount
of journalists
and i don't i that was that was an
accidental air quote some of these
people are actual journalists
they've been saying that we should be
looking into this for a long time as a
matter of fact the video
that i'm about to show you of dr stella
emanuel in dc
which went viral and then was taken down
uh you may remember this well
i at trump rallies last fall was out
there and i went out there with dennis
prager and i said dennis
we we didn't have masks on and i was
okay without having a mask and i said
dennis
well aren't you afraid you're out here
without a mask and you know dennis is
in his early 70s he said no i'm on
hydrochloroquine i'll i'll be just fine
uh now let's take a look at this video
that you may remember
from dr stella emanuel and this is last
summer
i'm a true testimony so i came here to
washington dc
to tell america nobody needs to get sick
this virus has a cure it is called
hydroxychloroquine
zinc and zitro max i know people want to
talk about masks hello
you don't need masks there is a cure i
know they don't want to open schools
no you don't need people to be locked
down there is prevention
and there is a cure i want to be very
clear about something that video was
was censored across the internet okay
that's number one
number two uh she's now saying well
she's saying then
that things that we now know are true
that the masks don't quite work
that's what fauci's emails have said
right we know this and we know that
lockdowns don't work
which is why the numbers in florida and
texas that were largely open
in many cases were far better than
places that locked down
like california and new york so that
woman who was then
you know call she was literally called a
white supremacist and and the rest of
the nonsense
and actually we were going to have her
on the show and i had to have a big
internal debate
whether we were going to do it because
we were already on you know we knew they
were looking at us already
and whether we would get our channel
deleted and everything else and i was
still setting up things
with locals to ensure that we'd be okay
on the on the back end of that
um i think you can see what's going on
here it's almost like
if you censor people then maybe
the censored people are actually saying
something kind of true and that's why
censorship
doesn't work um i mean a lot of people
owe that woman apology including jack
from twitter
and mark zuckerberg from facebook anyway
i'm not telling you it's 100
uh that the studies are 100 right right
like
i i'm not telling you that actually
maybe we'll try to get that doctor on
um we'll see we'll see if we can get him
be happy to talk about it so she may be
right
but the point is the media called her
crazy
and that's what the media seems to do
with anyone who dares say anything
close to the truth let's remember a few
months ago if you would
if you dared say that perhaps this was a
man-made virus
from a lab in wuhan that might have been
leaked either intentionally or not that
could have got you banned from twitter
now you're allowed to say it facebook
actually changed their policy altogether
if you had said that on facebook a few
months ago you were done
they were going to blow up your account
now they've actually made a statement
just in the last week because evidence
is leaking out
that you're actually okay if you were to
say these things so
man information war people we are in a
war on truth
and i guess i'm a general in the war on
truth
i'm a general in the war on truth and
you guys are part of my battalion
and i promise you we're gonna win this
thing
uh part two of my interview with sora
bamari which is a really really
interesting interview
the guy just wrote a book called the
unbroken thread
and he talks about his journey from
atheism to belief
and really why he believes that
traditional conservative values are the
the thing that can tether generations
together and he talks about some of the
faults
that he sees in liberalism we have some
really interesting touch points if
you haven't seen it i highly recommend
it the full episode is already up ad
free at rubinreport.locals.com
i'm going to be eating soft food for the
rest of the day because of my toothache
i hope you all enjoy your day
we'll be back tomorrow hopefully the new
york times doesn't slander anybody else
for the rest of the day so i can cover
some other stuff tomorrow and by the way
if you're someone at media matters
or at vox or at buzzfeed or at huffpo
give me some of the other crap ones or
at cnn or the new york times or
all the usual suspects if or vice or
slate
or puke or dog crap if you're
if you're one of the people at any of
these places of journalism it's like
guys
just don't be completely horrible and i
won't talk about you
you don't have to be great you don't
even have to be good you don't even have
to be average
just don't be completely horrible and i
will find some other stuff
stuff to talk about can you do that
could you do me a solid
do me a solid people puke that that is a
good website is a good website all right
all right see ya bye